so we are going to look at object object
detection with neural networks and we
are going to see if us humans detect
objects in the same way as neural
networks and to do this we are going to
trick the neural networks and see if we
are tricked in the same way
let's do some object detection we're
going to take a picture of something so
we've got some sunglasses here and then
i will email that to myself so we've got
the emailed image here which we called
image nothing too technical so we can
see the sunglasses there we're going to
go to matlab and we are going to first
of all we're going to load
our network and then what we're going to
do is we're going to get our image it's
a pre-trained network done by someone
else for object detection we have to
resize it to 224x224 this is the size of
image that resnet accepts so it has to
be that size
so we've got our image and then we can
classify it
and it'll give us two things back but
the one we're most interested in is this
variable called cat the category we
write that out we've got some sunglasses
in our image so
what's going on there there is a
repository of images online called
imagenet and what this is is it's just
an array of images that are annotated
with an object that's in them
and you can submit your neural network
or your artificial intelligence to see
how well you can classify these images
so at the moment the record is about 91
and there's a thousand categories so
this is a really difficult task so 91 is
pretty good and looking at all of the
categories as well they're not things
like um cat and dog they're a certain
breed of cat and a certain breed of dog
so actually very difficult and i imagine
most people probably get
between 95 and 98 something like that
i'm not exactly sure
so resnet that we're using um gets about
70 71 which might seem quite low but
when you've got a thousand categories
it's actually really good and the reason
we're using it as well is because it's a
bit smaller than some of the other
networks and because we're going to be
running it a lot of times okay so there
is a lot of data inside resnet it's a 44
megabyte download i think and probably
about two-thirds of that are just raw
numbers so there's millions and millions
of parameters in resnet there's been
some videos on convolutional neural
networks before and this is what we've
got here and with this amount of
variables it's very hard to understand
what's going on on the inside of the
network so there are some videos with
mike where he's talked about analyzing
the layers of the convolutional network
to find features and so on and so forth
and this is really good however in the
networks that are becoming very good at
this type of thing there's a lot of
layers and there's a lot of numbers in
there and as human beings we just can't
make sense of that much data it doesn't
mean anything to us so how do we try and
figure out a little bit of what's going
on in here if you give resnet an image
we will essentially get a vector of
numbers so we've got a thousand
categories any image could possibly be
and it will give you a value and all
these values will add up to one
hopefully um specifying how likely it
thinks a specific object is in that
image so for instance that picture of
the sunglasses might have been 0.1 cat
or something like that yeah exactly that
and we can actually see it on the
screens we've got category and we've got
res and res actually is this information
so it's basically a vector of size 1000
which specifies these odds so if we just
plot this when it comes up we should see
that it was a likelihood of 0.68
something like that now the other
probability is so low you can see a
little bit of a spike so it was it
thinks that something here so that big
pointy spike in a bit that's sunglasses
that's sunglasses and if we look at 766
so matlab counts from one but this list
is zero so we're looking for seven six
five
a rocking chair close enough should we
check another one it thinks there's a
little bit of rocking chair
that's like 422 so 421 banister
i suppose with the wood a little bit of
a chance but it's pretty sure that it's
just a pair of sunglasses so you're
right sometimes it's really not sure
and you get a lot more peaks and it just
happens to be the highest one and that's
what it classifies um as the object in
the image
okay so resnet gives you a thousand
numbers so if we just do a small one
we've got zero point one
zero point
three
and 0.6
so this could be cat dog giraffe so or
think that 0.6 being the highest value
um for this class it was only outputting
three classes you would say it's this
one which corresponds to a giraffe these
numbers are actually very precise
so they have um quite a few numbers
after the decimal point
so what we can do
is we can
have an image which we're going to give
to resnet
and we can focus on one of these classes
so this number here 0.3
could be 0.317928
okay so very precise so small changes in
the image will affect this if a giraffe
is in our picture and 0.6 what we can do
is we can just change one pixel in the
image just one and we can see how this
number changes
okay so if it goes ever so slightly up
what we could do is we could keep that
change and if it goes ever so slightly
down or doesn't change at all we can
reject that change and if we do this
over time we'll be able to make small
changes which will change this number
and hopefully increase it until that is
the category that is seen in the image
and not the giraffe so this this number
will go down and this one will go up by
only changing one pixel at a time and we
can keep on doing this and incrementally
move more towards a different
classification so we're going to do this
with a picture of the remote control
this is something that we all know what
this is uh this is my remote control um
from home that i took a photo of what
we're gonna do is we're gonna use this
image and we are gonna try and trick
resnet into misclassifying it and let's
say we're gonna turn this remote control
into
something else so the classes i chose
are
coffee mug computer keyboard envelope
golf ball and photocopier so we're
trying to change the original image here
of the remote control into another image
according to resnet by just making these
small incremental changes so we've got
our remote control and then we can look
and see what um the change that we're
made to turn this into a coffee mug and
here we go
so that's it for all the changes it's
made to the image it now thinks that
that is
over 99 likelihood of being a coffee mug
can you see the coffee mug there if it
is it's uh it's definitely by one of the
more abstract artists exactly right and
then we can go computer keyboard i mean
there's some space here surrounded by
some boundaries i mean it's loose some
things happen this is an envelope
doesn't like an envelope this is a
photocopier and
we have a golf ball here which is
slightly different it just seems to me
that there might be some attempt to get
the dimples on the golf ball
i mean again it's very very loose we can
categorically say that if we gave that
to a person they would say there's a
remote control in that image
and some noise and i can imagine that
you know that's you've cropped that
remote control to be on a white
background but if that was say a carpet
or something like that
you wouldn't even notice the difference
exactly yeah um especially if it was
higher resolution as well and you're
less able to see those dots um yeah
that's very much the case
um so something made me think after
doing this maybe
maybe there's something about remote
control which is just inherently
confusing maybe i picked a class which
is difficult for it to recover from and
move to a different class not ever
trained to do that so i thought i'll
give it a blank slate and start with a
completely blank image
and then see what representations would
it make if it doesn't have to change
anything it can just go from blank image
to whatever it wants so the same thing
just making one incremental change at a
time and adding it up until it's 99 sure
it's a certain glass this is our coffee
mug that looks like the world at night
from the iss with just a few lights over
africa not a bad shot computer keyboard
if we're being truly optimistic
that could be a key but it's not the
best rendition of a keyboard this is an
envelope i say there's not much there
but it's i mean these are all 99 sure so
it is really sure that these are certain
things so here's an interesting one
actually the golf ball now it's
definitely not a golf ball
but it seems that there is an attempt
there to make something that looks like
the dimples in a golf ball if you're
trying to give it the benefit of doubt
and that's probably the feature that is
most looking for that's what it thinks a
golf ball is so not necessarily
round per se but these dimples and the
last one is the photocopier so
something's going on in resnet in a way
which we just can't rationalize i'm
pretty sure that if you edited a picture
and put some pixels in certain places we
wouldn't be fooled by it so something
like resnet could make a pretty decent
attempt to a driverless car so it could
probably stay within in between the
lines
do some accelerating and braking for
motorway driving i think it would be
pretty good but when you have things
like this and things you can't really
interpret very well like a little ray of
sunshine reflecting off a water drop on
a leaf like 20 yards over there and some
other things
you could get some strange behavior
however on aggregate
you wouldn't i think so it to actually
make an effort to try and sort of spoof
these networks and make them misclassify
something um is like a dedicated task
for it to happen naturally i think is
exceptionally rare however um you just
don't want it to happen at all and it'll
be great if you could understand this
and it would be it'd be great for sort
of just our understanding and our
happiness with this if it did
draw a golf ball or something like that
so when there's lots of blank space the
envelope was quite sparse yeah there's
not much going on in envelope so it
looked like it made a lot more changes
for a golf ball than an envelope but i
was thinking how good can we get this i
mean with the minimum number of changes
minimum number of changes so
because you mentioned it was on a white
background so the change a bit more
obvious but can we get it close enough
so that
it's really there's really not much
going on there so obviously i've shot
myself in the foot there with it being a
white background because you can notice
all the changes but what i did is i went
back to my trusty friend the genetic
algorithm which we spoke about on a
previous video so if you're in the
desert and you had one rucksack you'd
have to fill it with the most valuable
items and the fitness function of the
genetic algorithm is just to try and
maximize the value
of a certain
a certain category so the number
attracts a certain category so that it
changes
it from being remote control so it
doesn't have to be 99
but if the highest number if it's like
for example 70 sure that it's a remote
control but we're going to try and
change um
the likelihood of it being golf but
we're going to try and increase that
until the golf ball is higher
than the original image remote control
and we're going to see what that looks
like and we're only going to give it a
100 pixels to play with so we've got 224
by 224 which is about
50 000.
something like that um pixels and we're
going to change 100 of them so can we
change the um
the categorization resnet gives the
remote control by just changing 100
pixels
you can which is good so we'll just go
through the same five again um we've got
our coffee mug here
and there we go that's with 100 pixels
being changed a lot less information
there and that does just look like noise
we can't do anything with that
information and similarly with computer
keyboard 100 pixels
not too much of a change there compared
to the others and this is our envelope
very similar golf ball now doesn't
really even have the concept of a dimple
in the golf ball so it just looks like
random noise and same with the
photocopier
and i think if we push this hard enough
we could probably get it down to about
50 70 pixels or something like that
these networks are exceptionally good at
categorizing
um which objects are are in images
however they seem to be doing it in a
very different way to us human beings it
doesn't quite tie in with our intuition
when we did this originally um we didn't
know what was going to happen we didn't
know if the genetic algorithm or
iteratively hill climbing through the
image would make something that looked
like a coffee mug that would make sense
we didn't know that but it turns out it
just makes um garbage and puts it on the
image and yeah change this
classification
in particular what we are doing is
to
3d print these kind of
systems such that in future they can
actually be manufactured together with
the robot body and have integrity and
that's going to be slow except it's not
slow because there's hardly any ones in
here